nous revenons donc à l'extérieur de ce
palais du pharo
et devant cette ville de marseille le
point du logement c'est un des problèmes
qui se posent à toutes les grandes
villes de france
on le sait et à marseille où la
population est passée en 20 ans de six
cent mille habitants à 1 million
d'habitants la crise a été amplifiée
encore par l'existence d'une population
d'origine maghrébine qui est extrêmement
importante je crois qu'il ya à peu près
65 mille soixante dix mille personnes
originaires d'afrique du nord ici il ya
quelques mois encore un logement un
ensemble de logements de 43 logements
dans la cité ruisseau mirabeau a été
inaugurée pour à l'ensemble qui est
adapté à ces populations et pourtant
quelques problèmes de logement ce poste
encore notamment pour des familles lire
vos jambes des gens dans les conditions
d'existence sont très difficiles les
gens qui ne vivent pas comme tout le
monde et qu'on appelle pudiquement les
gens du quart monde ici à marseille dans
la cité des renaude près de 900
personnes dont plusieurs centaines
d'enfants maghrébins gitans quais noirs
vivent dans les pires conditions sans
eau courante et sans sanitaires dans la
boue et les ordures ici enfin on a honte
de l'endroit où on habite
comme cette petite fille qui n'a pas
voulu être filmé ce que je veux pas leur
dire comment ça devient parra comme ça
je ne peux pas leur dire que j'habite à
2001 comme ça comme ça ma maîtresse oil
si je crois ou les amis es tu avec l'âge
alors je n'ai même jamais d'amis et elle
croit que tu as vite ou tes amis le hlm
et là de l'autre côté de la rue
inaccessible pour ceux d'en bas chez
mohamed c'est presque normal ici l'on
vit à 12 dans deux pièces un couple avec
10 enfants entassés les uns sur les
autres les enfants dorment sur des
couvertures à même le sol
imaginez ce que peuvent être l'hygiène
ou les nuits dans de telles conditions
mais ce qu'il y a de plus difficile pour
moi mais ce sont les planes de ses
enfants qui ne comprennent pas que l'on
puisse vivre comme ils vivent
les envahit le de chaque fois pas passer
la maison ça va pas nous de rester comme
le cochon à la maison hélas deux
versants la mise en spot de biasca
couzier sipa beau papa et moi fois la
femme de mohammed accompli chaque matin
les gestes rituels de toutes les mères
quand leurs enfants vont à l'école et
chaque matin elle s'interroge elle se
demande pourquoi depuis 15 ans qu'ils
sont en france leur demande de logement
et refuser chaque année pourtant
dit-elle
nous ne demandons rien d'autre qu'un
logement et le salaire de mohammed qui
travaille dans une usine d'appareils de
chauffage est suffisant pour payer un
loyer
à l'heure du déjeuner nous avons
rencontré moustafa un des fils de la
dame
quel âge as tu vu celle là et tu
travailles dans son jour est étudié avec
des parents ici oui oui et comment ça se
passe votre or ici c'est à ce moment là
et nous manquions n'y a pas assez de
place tous les jours elle d'aller
chercher l'eau venait tout ça tous les
joueurs devaient chercher et on
travaille tous ceux ci vont à l'école
toujours il faut qu'elle sort elles
reviennent saurait rien toucher l'eau et
après si l'on pense même nom la pâte et
d'abaisser les femmes et les hommes la
bonne je trouve en parlant par sp auchan
là bas c'est honteux quand même et ça ça
fait qu'on ne peut pas maintenant
personnes ont refusé de payer
il ya des rats ici signalé depuis de la
cave où les soirs elle se promène comme
dans la sphère de la paix
et puis il y à aussi l'humidité pour les
enfants tous les cimes ils mandatent ou
l'ami croit le dr et surtout photo fois
par semaine au moins 2000 logements est
demandée tous les jours il donne
monsieur vient à la lisière d'un guet
apens ni le plus frappant de cécité de
la honte c'est l'exubérant des enfants
des enfants que les gens des hlm d'à
côté n'aime pas voir près de chez eux
des enfants montrées du doigt qui auront
du mal à s'insérer dans la société
je veux faire c'est le racisme etc ect